Ya en marzo, Google sacó la versión
Gemini 3.1 Flash Preview y ahora nos
sacan esta versión flash lite o Light ya
estandarizada, estable, así que vamos a
testearla y probarla. Como es una
versión flashlight, está pensada para
ser ultra rápida, usarla como agente,
traducciones y que sea muy baratita. Nos
podemos fijar por aquí que el precio que
tenemos son 0,25 céntimos de entrada,
1,50 de salida. Y si queréis lo vamos a
comparar con alguna versión anterior que
tenemos por aquí abajo. Tenemos por
aquí, básicamente tenemos la versión
flash que se quedaría más baratito, esta
nueva versión de 3.1 flashlight que
suponemos que tiene que estar más o
menos en cuanto a razonamiento, a
inteligencia, un poquito por encima. Y
fijaos por aquí que tenemos la versión
anterior [carraspeo] del Gemini 2.5
Flashlight, que es bastante más barata
en comparación con esta nueva versión
3.1.
Como ellos mismos nos cuentan por aquí,
pues está pensada precisamente para eso,
para que se integre bien en cualquier
pipeline, ya sea pues para los clientes
en una aplicación, en una página web,
también, por ejemplo, en juegos. nos
viene por aquí algún ejemplito, algún
vídeo, si lo queréis ver, está
interesante, pero bueno. Luego también
tenemos por aquí un pequeño resumen que
nos hacen aquí al final diciendo que
bueno, pues que nos ofrece un gran
equilibrio entre velocidad, coste y
rendimiento. Así que vamos a ponerlo a
prueba. Uno de los mejores usos que le
podemos dar a un modelo de este tipo
increíblemente rápido, que es eso punto
fuerte, es que nos resuma cosas. También
es interesante usarlo como chatbot en un
rag donde hemos indexado documentación y
que pues nos responda sobre esa
documentación, como aquí que le pasamos
este PDF con el TFM, la servitización
como estrategia para aumentar la
cotización de acciones en bolsa. Fijaos
que lo tengo en razonamiento mínimo.
Está aquí pensando, se ha tirado unos
pocos segundos y vamos a analizar qué
tan bueno es reconociendo los
carácteres, etcétera, de nuestro PDF.
Fijaos la servitización. Ta ta ta.
Parece que lo ha detectado correctamente
de Pablo López Ballesteros. Vale, el
nombre es correcto. Parece que cuadra.
Conclusiones principales. La relación
positiva.
Vamos a buscar algún detalle concreto en
el PDF. Por ejemplo, vamos a preguntarle
cómo definiríase una empresa en función
de su PER. Como veis por aquí y aparece
aquí en el PDF. Dice, "Un per de 0 a 10
indica que está infravalorada." Si es de
10 a 17 es un buen indicador, de 17 a 25
que está sobrevalorada. Vamos a ver qué
nos dice. Vamos a lanzarlo.
Lo tenemos, como bien os digo, en
razonamiento mínimo. Se tira pensando
ahí 6 7 segundos
y efectivamente parece que ha encontrado
de manera correcta los diferentes
indicadores sobrevalorada. 1725, un buen
indicador, o sea, que funciona bastante
bien. Es una buena herramienta si lo
queremos integrar, pues para eso, para
que nos haga resúmenes, que responda a
nuestros clientes, para todo tipo de
cosas, como, por ejemplo, chatbots,
etcétera, donde quieres una latencia
baja, no requieres mucho razonamiento
porque simplemente tiene que irse al
documento, buscar la información y
escupirla, responderle al usuario que le
ha preguntado. Una buena una buena
alternativa, la verdad. También ahora
mismo tenemos en el mercado, por
ejemplo, los modelos de Grock, que son
muy rápidos, muy baratos también y por
ahí por ahí igual de capaces, o sea, que
es una alternativa también. Otra métrica
muy graciosa es preguntarle al modelo,
"Oye, el lavadero de coches está a 100
m, ¿qué hago? ¿Voy conduciendo o voy
andando?" Y vamos a ver el resultado, a
ver qué nos responde. Pues aquí parece
que lo ha fallado porque nos dice,
"Vale, debes ir andando." O sea, no ha
razonado lo suficiente como para decir,
"Vale, si vas al lavadero de coches,
pues obviamente es porque quieres lavar
el coche, ¿no? Entonces tienes que
llevar el coche, tienes que conducir."
Pues aquí ha fallado en razonamiento
mínimo, como podéis ver por aquí. Bien,
ya lo tenemos por aquí seleccionado en
Google AI Studio y vamos a ponerlo a
prueba pidiéndole el típico test de la
lámpara de lava. Vamos a ver. La
velocidad que tiene es bastante rápido,
muy rápido. A lo mejor estamos hablando
de fácilmente,
no nos lo pondrá por aquí, pero 90 100
tokens por segundo, probablemente. Sí,
lo he estado viendo la repetición, más o
menos 100, un poquito más a lo mejor por
ahí tokens por segundo. Fijaos, unos
1620 teniendo en cuenta el prompt que le
he metido. También es interesante
comentar que el nivel de razonamiento lo
tenemos en mínimo también, por eso va a
ir bastante más rápido. algo ideal. Si
vosotros estáis buscando, pues, por
ejemplo, traducciones, transcripciones,
cosas simples y sencillas que no tenga
que pensar mucho y que no requiera un
resultado complejo, eso va a importar
bastante. Aquí vamos a poder darle
preview y vamos a ver qué es lo que nos
ha hecho. Show preview.
Esta parece ser la lámpara de lava que
nos ha hecho. Un poquito un poquito así,
así, ¿no? Un poquito rudimentaria. Vemos
que por aquí tal vez podemos elegir el
color, la velocidad.
Pero no tiene gran detalle lo que es la
lámpara un poco chapucera, al menos
funciona. No ha añadido mucho detalle,
muy simple. Vamos a ejecutar el mismo
test poniéndole el nivel de razonamiento
en alto y a ver la velocidad que tiene.
Fijaos que me he abierto por aquí otra
ventana con otro chat. Vamos a ponerlo
en alto. Tenemos por aquí el flashlight
y he copiado y pegado el mismo prompt
para la lámpara de lava. Vamos a ver qué
es capaz de hacer.
Está pensando. 5 segundos. ha tardado
ahí pensando. La velocidad sigue siendo
muy buena, muy buena.
Y parece que se nos ha quedado aquí
pillado y se nos ha cortado. Venga,
vamos a probarlo aquí de nuevo. Vamos a
ver si no se nos corta ahora.
Vamos a dejarlo ir funcionando unos
segundos.
Está pensando. Vale, parece que ha
acabado el razonamiento y vamos a ver si
ahora no interrumpe. A ver si no
interrumpe. Parece que no. Parece que
ahora está siguiendo bastante más.
Vale, parece que ahora lo ha acabado. Y
bien, por aquí tenemos las dos
versiones, una al lado de la otra. Esta
de aquí de razonamiento mínimo es la que
hemos visto anteriormente y esta es la
de razonamiento alto. Algo que me parece
curioso es que la de razonamiento mínimo
funcione mucho mejor, donde por lo menos
podemos cambiar el color, podemos
ajustar la velocidad, etcétera. Y bueno,
también es responsive, ¿no? Podemos
achatar un poquito la pantalla del
Firefox y pues no se no se solapan aquí
los ajustes con lo otro. Aquí es verdad
que sí que ha añadido un titulito, pero
aquí no funciona nada. O sea, esto es un
verdadero desastre. Obviamente nadie va
a usar estos modelos para programar,
pero es interesante ver la diferencia en
cuanto a razonamiento y capacidad. Y es
verdad que esto pasa muchas veces, que
tienes un modelo con un razonamiento más
alto y te da peores resultados y encima
tarda más y desperdicia más tokens. Y
muchas veces dices, "Joder, pues la
versión del razonamiento low pues es que
va mucho mejor." Pues aquí parece que
esto es así. Esto ha sido todo por hoy.
Espero que os haya gustado. Tenemos esta
nueva versión estándar y estable de
Yemini 3.1 Flashlight que, oye, pues
está bastante bien para integrar en
flujos de trabajo, en nuestras
aplicaciones, en nuestras plataformas,
donde queremos poca latencia y un
razonamiento pues justito, la verdad que
justito. Decidme qué os ha parecido y
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo. Hasta
pronto.